- So let's talk Stevie
Wonder cause I know y'all
are friends.
Do y'all like literally
hang out all the time
and like what?
- Stevie is probably--
I'm gonna tell you
something, I've been spending
my whole life with him
thinking, he can see.
I know he can see.
- He can see, I thought you
said sing, (laughs) oh my...
- No, he can see.
Listen, the story I tell
that's the funniest, I went
to his house, he says, "Wanna
hear a new song, I've got
"it in the car, come on go with me."
We go out to the car,
he says, "You sit on the
passenger side, I'll sit
on the driver's side".
He goes in, he cranks the car
up, he puts the tape in right?
And then he does this...
(audience laughs)
and starts driving back down the driveway.
- No, sir.
- And I scream, said
"Stevie, what are you doing?"
and he said, "Ah, gotcha didn't I?"
(everyone applauds and laughs)
I would hate to get around
him because every time
I would get around him
I would not wanna give a
phrase to him because
he'll write a song with it.
If I say, "How you doin' Stevie?"
How you doin' oh...
(everyone laughs)
And then I'll say, "I'll see you later"
See you later.